hey guys what's going on we got to talk
about new Justice League footage new
Aquaman footage from the Aquaman movie
and the Batgirl movie if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything I do DC and Marvel videos
every week there's even a flash ring
giveaway going on I'll explain at the
end of the video but at CinemaCon they
screen brand new Justice League footage
that had a bunch of new flash scenes and
a whole bunch of stuff from the Aquaman
movie so I'll explain what that is
WonderCon is happening this weekend they
might actually drop the footage then so
if they do then I'll do new video but
it's actually pretty cool because the
Aquaman footage teases a bunch of new 52
stuff the extra Justice League footage
started with Alfred saying master Wayne
you've been working as if there's no
tomorrow trying to build this team and
then Wonder Woman enters the big hangar
where he's building the flying fox here
and he's working on it gets pissed that
she's able to just waltz right through
his crazy Batman level security and he
explains he's building a special troop
carrier she says the attack is already
here there's a brand new scene with
Wonder Woman using her sword she loses
it midair it starts falling flash
catches it and runs it back to her and
then later there's like a funny moment
where he sees the bat-signal and Geeks
out and says hey that's your symbol that
means we have to go in Batman looks at
him nods and says yes we have to go so
the big deal with the Justice League
footage is that it just showed up a
whole bunch more dialogue you know
typically like the first big trailer is
just a lot of the big action set-pieces
a lot of the craziness like look at this
ancient battle with dark side you have
the Atlanteans fighting side by side
with the Amazons this is crazy the next
trailer will probably include some of
these scenes just more of the characters
interacting with each other and less
punching but like I said you know
WonderCon is happening this weekend so
they're supposed to be a Wonder Woman
panel in a Justice League panel so
either they're going to show off the old
trailers again it'll be the exact same
footage or they'll drop the new stuff
when they came on stage to do their big
presentation none of them talked but
Henry Cavill was there he even brought
his dog Cal but cyborg wrote in on the
Flash's shoulder so that should give you
an idea that Ezra Miller is actually
pretty strong because cyborg is huge but
they have a great energy they were
having a lot of fun
The Wonder Woman people were there too
not a lot of new footage the big thing
was the Aquaman concept art so they
showed off some concept footage because
they haven't started shooting it Jason
Momoa literally
took off yesterday from Las Vegas to go
start filming the Aquaman movie so they
are rolling right now but what they
showed off was straight out of the new
52 so if you know who at land is they
showed off the ancient King that's what
they were billing him as he's a skeleton
who looks like an ancient Atlantean but
his name in the comics was at land he
was the original king of Atlantis the
seven kingdoms of Atlantis and there was
this big coup he was kicked out his
family was killed he came back with his
magical Trident in sync all Seven
Kingdoms so when you talk about the rise
of the seven seas you're talking about
new 52 stuff so if you guys want I can
do a separate video about that but
they're just doing a lot of new 52 stuff
in visually aesthetically they're
inspired by that too because they showed
up a whole bunch of Atlantis and it
looks very new 52 Black Manta was
wearing a comic-book helmet so if you're
worried that they weren't going to do
comic book Black Manta
do not be afraid they are fully going
for it they're going to do the crazy
helmet it's going to be awesome
there were Atlanteans riding sharks in
the battle so they're going all out it
was his grand vision of Atlantis that
was right off of the page of the comics
so James Wan is a great director he said
a lot of funny things about the footage
too he was talking about how he wants
the audience to experience Atlantis for
the first time with Aquaman so we're
going to see the origin obviously but
then he was just talking about some of
the really cool footage they were
showing off saying that you know you
think that they're driving around and
ships underwater but you get in close
and you see that it sharks other
underwater creatures that they're riding
around so it's going to be this
otherworldly crazy place think about the
world of Avatar in that movie like how
different it looks from earth so that's
going to be the same deal with Aquaman
and Atlantis we got to see concepts of
ocean master but really like the
exciting thing in addition to just
seeing how cool Atlantis look was the
idea that the ancient king is actually
going to be one of the antagonists of
the movie but really ocean master I
think is going to be the ultimate
villain he'll have a much more personal
stake in it but they might actually be
doing the rise of the seven seas
storyline the lost kingdoms of Atlantis
so start reading your Aquaman new 52 but
throne of Atlantis is probably good
reference to they'll be elements of that
in the film he's meant to be the true
king of Atlantis even though ocean
masters not too hot on the idea his
relationship with mera in the idea that
the
ancient King at land has come back from
the dead and is trying to reclaim his
empire so it's going to be totally crazy
but if there any other bonus videos that
you guys want me to do just let me know
in the comments like I said WonderCon is
this weekend so they'll probably be some
kind of new footage for something so
I'll totally do a video whenever at pose
the Batgirl news I know a lot of people
are freaking out about Joss Whedon doing
a Batgirl movie they haven't said
anything about what the story is going
to be they said they made the deal last
month so he's actually been working on
it for a while now usually they don't
start writing a script till they
actually sign a contract and start
getting paid so in the way that Zack
Snyder pulled a lot from like really
iconic moments in Batman's history
especially Dark Knight Returns Batgirl
will pry be the same there'll be no
specific comic book story but I'm
expecting a more new 52 version so it's
not going to be Oracle in the wheelchair
if you've been a longtime fan you've
mostly known her as Oracle but I don't
expect them to do Killing Joke or
anything like that that's a little more
hardcore than I think they're going to
do and most people really didn't like
the animated treatment of that so I
don't think that they're anxious to
revisit that what would you guys think
about them letting Jared Leto be in the
movie as the Joker now they wouldn't do
Killing Joke but they would let Batgirl
beat the crap out of him his portrayal
has been so divisive I feel like as long
as you use him as a punching bag he's
totally safe whatever plotline you want
to give him but the Joker like the
problem is you don't want to overuse him
because he's gonna have to show up
during the birds-of-prey movie because
he's so tied to the Harley Quinn
character that also raises the question
of Harley Quinn appearing in the back
girl movie like just because she's a
female character do you surround her
with other strong female characters who
are those going to be who are you going
to bring into the Canon we'll Catwoman
be in it like what kind of villains will
she be facing there's a whole host of
Batman villains that you could put into
Batgirl videos that you just don't have
room for in the Batman solo movie
between this the Nightwing movie in the
Batman solo movie you have like three
places where you can populate the DC EU
with a bunch of different cool Batman
villains so you don't all have to try
and blow your wad on the Batman solo
movie the really easy workaround then
they did this during Batman V Superman
you don't even have to go this far is
when they're looking at the dossier
online where it's like oh look at all
these metas there's a guy that can run
really fast there's a guy who talks to
fish you could even do a sub
version of that where you just have a
list that Amanda Waller has of known
metas that are Batman villains so you
can be like oh my god all these
characters exist and then you could
actually bring them onto screen when you
get to these other solo movies so you
can use people like calculator Clayface
Firefly people that you've actually seen
in other media like Firefly went on
Gotham and they also used a version of
calculator on arrow but it's also a
roundabout way to bring back Suicide
Squad characters before they get the
sequel out they're still trying to
figure that movie out too but all we
really know is that Joss Whedon is
writing producing and directing the
movie so I definitely think it'll be
solid if they can pull it off hopefully
he'll stay with the project there won't
be some sort of creative differences
down the line please don't leave us Joss
Whedon but hopefully they'll work in a
Nightwing cameo obviously Batman's going
to show up somewhere in there maybe in a
small way but other than it being inside
the DC EU it will be connected to the
Justice League and all the other films
they haven't said much about what their
plans are for it so just like the
Aquaman movie they'll be prequel
elements and there'll be stuff happening
in present day so just expect them to
treat the movie as if you've never read
a Batgirl comic before but you have a
vague idea of who she is so if you're
hardcore comic-book band there'll be a
lot of Easter eggs in there but it's not
going to be like a specific comic book
story so is there any other bonus videos
for Batgirl you guys want me to do just
let me know in the comments what's going
to happen next is is there'll be a new
game of Thrones
you've been asking for a Legion video
too so I'll do a video for the finale
but congratulations to the new flash
ring giveaway winner Ken Watanabe please
private message being on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for that to post
you can click here for the new Game of
Thrones trailer and you can click here
for the Justice League trailer again
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video
you